hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
Freddy's I'm really hoping this is gonna
be the last episode is I don't know how
long it's gonna take me to be nightmare
mode just judging on xx mode in the past
but I got through night five relatively
quickly so let's find out what the story
has to say
in this last night what else awaits us
thanks
welcome information was that I'm just
gonna take the death on this one because
I know that I didn't want to interrupt
any of the
the actual sounds with what's going on
let me just test oh so it doesn't do an
audio error right away I have two
chances okay so that's good that's good
didn't you know it's good to know I'm
not gonna die yet maybe I could just
last the day if I just get you know no
oxygen in me it's probably fine hello is
usually where foxy comes rampaging in
but that's not a thing that happens
anymore apparently cuz foxy isn't okay
so that's that anyway I just wanted to
get through that so that I could get to
an actual attempt without having to
worry about talking or making the noises
over the phone call because I want the
phone call now that I know I think I can
do this pretty well like I'm not I'm not
you know fooling anybody here I'm fairly
good at the game at this point like
that's not me bragging or anything
I have played five nights at Freddy's 4
so unbelievably long like I really know
my [ __ ] when it comes to this game y'all
yeah I've never used that tunnel
before but I'm feeling slightly sassy I
don't know what else awaits me in this
nightmare of this world
but it has got to be careful about other
animatronics in the I'm assuming come
back here wherever you are come back
here come back here there you are
video err god dammit that's quick video
is gonna go out the audio is gonna go
out everything's gonna go out
immediately
like I only have a set amount of time to
look at the camera and we have a set
amount of time before the ventilation is
just gonna go out anyway or if someone
else decides to stop by and be a dick
and then get my [ __ ] all long kurd I
don't know I don't know words right now
okay flan curd is the best I can come up
with hi foxy how are you okay I got some
tea and biscuits if you want that that's
the cool thing that Fox is like I think
what does the Fox say what does the Fox
say
what can I do anything
god damn it I knew something was gonna
happen just didn't know where or how or
why and why is my camera out and why is
my ventilation out again it's not going
well everything is the son of a [ __ ]
okay there is get to two please thank
you I'm gonna go ahead and slam this
down cuz I feel like it yes did you go
back there I've gone back there I'm
gonna do it again stay here thank you
listen already moved he probably already
moved down already dead probably
probably probably probably
oh god I'm [ __ ] well it's gonna be fun
for a while we'll talk about a process
goddammit
it's gonna be tough foxy why just shine
in your eyes I don't have a camera to
look at you you're so pretty
maybe I need to look at the foxy head on
the wall maybe that'll satiate his
bloodlust I don't know where he is I
think he was in that room I think I saw
him in the top corner that one I just
got to be quick on the resets cuz like
as soon as I'm done I gotta go right
back I got over right back getting my
old instincts back oh he's there go back
there that's over here don't need to do
anything so he's gonna be over there so
I'm gonna get him back to eight no I'm
gonna get him all the way to ten
hopefully gonna reset the audio that's
fine and then par the ventilations gonna
go next or the camera system or
something but I'm gonna keep him over at
10 for at least a little bit I'm gonna
go ahead and reset the ventilation but
that's why I'm not gonna matter because
the hallucinations gonna come by so I
mean [ __ ] which vented he just going am
i [ __ ]
oh I'm [ __ ] already saw my this bone
oh god no please dear God no no please
no don't don't do it
no oh no no no please
[Music]
right okay
okay oh hey how's it going okay now I'm
gonna die well I was waiting for the
moment that I was gonna die there but
you brought it to me so I really
appreciate that that's something that I
really cherish of our friendship I'm
gonna do one because I don't know what's
gonna do to you maybe you'll just go out
the door and leave forever and then I'll
be happy happy happy
Oh what god damn it means I'm dead no
matter what it's like I can't
there's no time to sit and wait for two
things at once like you have to pick you
have to pick one or the other because
otherwise you're just going to be
totally and completely screwed I mean
there's a few places that are just gonna
be blind guesses as to if he's close or
not so like there's like a few safe bets
but they're still even not that good
even if they're supposedly safe because
no matter what something's gonna come
after you does event those event that
was been me talking is causing me to
miss out on things she'll still come on
come on good good okay perfect perfect
that give me a little bit of time
where's my Cowabunga friend he's back
over there so we went a long way back so
does that mean that I can oh [ __ ] okay
video error I just gotta get back to 9
so I can bounce him back and forth at
least for a little bit away from me
audio first and then I'm gonna do
another trick over at 10 hopefully
that'll be enough time because I think
in the time that it takes for your audio
to normally reset there's a time that it
takes for it to naturally do whatever it
does anyway I don't even know if that
God I'm aware he needs to be but it's a
little bit like hopefully I'm also gonna
do a safe bet over here at 5 immediately
fix my audio and hope like because right
now I'm just guessing right now it's all
guesswork but I guess the trick is just
get as many boxes done and done I'm done
done done done it done got so far the
first time oh [ __ ] what which one
[Music]
there's no time there's no time
god dammit he was instantly gone [ __ ] I
leaned up a benefit of the camera going
out is that I don't have to see any of
the other animatronics they don't bother
me
they're not gonna be an issue this guy's
gonna be an issue
oh [ __ ] what fans what vent which one
which one oh [ __ ] cool cool cool cool
that means who's gonna go back to five
and that means he's gonna find another
vent at least closing them off from that
option it's all about responses like
playing a game of chess with this
[ __ ] location chess where'd he go
anywhere I don't know what that means I
don't know where he is that's a bad sign
obviously no God oh [ __ ] no god dammit
clicking the wrong thing it's just like
flashbacks from one of the early games
like when I played 20 modem for five
nights at Freddy's 1 1 miss click one
miss click is like killed you oh god I
don't know if he's anywhere near that
I'm gonna try to but I don't know if
he's anywhere near enough to beat it -
okay there he is ok he's there he's
there it's good that means I can close
this oh just in time baby oh holy crap
oh they give me some time
holy [ __ ] ok just cleaned out the vent
he's back at five was that just him
going into another vent somewhere please
tell me that was just him coming out
good good good okay just try to go back
in I don't know why frankly I don't care
he's popped out though and he probably
back in five now so that's okay that's
okay we're doing good I just can't let
him over in the to vend now
was this oh he's there okay he's back
there that means they can plug in him to
five so if I can just get him to five
I'll be okay five baby
delicious audio shits 5 a.m. hey hey
how's it going
I'll let you go back to 2 you [ __ ]
make it I'm making a call son of a [ __ ]
I beat nightmare mode in 17 minutes and
55 seconds it burns it burns pretty
fazbear's fright burns to the ground a
new local attraction based on an ancient
pizzeria chains burned down overnight
authorities have not ruled out foul play
but at the mode it seems to have been
fall but caused by faulty writing wiring
very little was found at the scene a few
items were savage will be sold at public
ah yes ok what did they do
will they do I got 2 stars how do I get
3 you son of [ __ ]
okay so there must be there must be some
other secret that I don't know of yet in
terms of beating and getting the happy
ending because I've managed to be
nightmare mode and to be honest I'm
either really good at this game now or
this was not nearly as hard as the other
ones I think what happened is this one
was not luck based the other ones were
luck based and that's why they took so
long because he had to be perfect at the
perfect moment but this one was very
luck based either way actually let me go
back to the other screen because it was
a bit more quick more peaceful this is
actually a weird moment for me because I
kind of know that five nights at freddys
is over after the third one like the
saga and the story of five nights at
freddys has come to a close but what's
weird is that I don't know everything
that is a mystery in this game yet there
is so much secret built into these games
and I just don't know it I don't know if
it was just pure skill that got me
through that last level so quickly or if
the fact that it wasn't luck based like
the last ones which meant that you had
to be perfect at the perfect time to be
able to beat it but this was an
adventure and I'm so glad that you guys
chose my videos to watch over everyone
that played in I I'm not saying they're
bad like their videos are bad but I'm
just glad that you guys stuck with me
through this adventure and I'm not done
yet I still need to get the good ending
but I don't know how so I need to
research this I need to find it out I
might have to play through the game a
couple more times just to be able to get
all the secrets again but either way I
just want to say thank you guys so much
for watching thank you guys so much for
supporting me through these five nights
at Freddy's adventures it's not over yet
because it's going to be a lot more five
nights at Freddy's coming at you soon as
soon as I can figure out how to beat
this and also hopefully some more
animations and other cool stuff
and fan games of course but I won't play
too many of those so thank you again
everybody so much for watching thank you
for joining me on this adventure we're
not done yet don't want to be very clear
about that but for now I'd be nightmare
mode I can claim that so thank you
everybody so much for watching check out
all the other five nights at Freddy's
stuff in the description below or in the
annotations over there always I will see
you
[Music]
okay